do great did I how was my aim was it
okay
[Laughter]
you have to ride a horse and this you
know there's no special effects you were
on that horse how was that because you
had to massively gallop and ride and do
all that stuff like how was that
it was very very painful that's why I
seem to remember I remember I had to
take like five baths a day because my
muscles were so painful
um but I I managed to not fall off the
horse which I was very pleased about
thank goodness no you rode very very
well
um and were a true Prince I mean do gray
you you were the only one who could have
helped us make this film in that way
that
this was a such a lesson of how we
didn't have to dismiss the other gender
in order to empower ourselves yeah I
think it was ahead of its time in the
movie I I remember reading it and
thinking wow this is really quite
Forward Thinking and it's a movie about
empowerment and giving all these young
women around the world who who were
going to watch the movie a sense of um
a great example of how you don't how
young women don't have to you know look
up to men in order to be led and to be
set an example of and they're and they
have the ability to you know to to take
control of their own lives and I think
that your character really
was such a wonderful example of that and
I thought it was a Thoroughly Modern
film and I was just really happy to be
to be part of that yeah absolutely
Melanie I mean what was it
for you what was like a tone or a
shoulder shouldering of a responsibility
or anything that inspired you like how
did you enter into
helping create this world as we all kind
of banded together and took hands and
were like all right let's make this I
mean I was just in such immense
gratitude about getting to do this film
with people I just admired so much and
this one you became like my sister
hanging out in our house in the woods it
was so fun and you just inspired me
every day Angelica really it was so
giving and gracious and just taught me
so much and was so loving and
I like our dinner patties The Fringe
nightclubs and maybe we danced on the
bar one night and they were like
they made us get down yes yeah of course
I do the grotch oh my God I mean we
really did we had the best time this
time you know and Megan how did you
not go archetypal and make something
really extraordinary out of your
character well this is my first film I
had only really done theater projects up
to this point so I think Angelica
deserves a ton of credit for really kind
of taking me under her wing and saying
you know stick with me kid we got this
kind of thing I'm just so glad that we
were all in it together and it's so true
about Angelica and I have a little story
about
I was in my kitchen and we were talking
about who could play this you know very
Infamous role and they're you know there
weren't all these retellings at that
point like this was a very sort of
unapproached kind of genre and so like
who could step in as like the famous
stepmother and
um I really wanted it to be Angelica
Houston and I think there was you know
like an impasse of maybe she wouldn't be
able to do it or you know could it work
in her schedule or did she even want to
and I remember just going screw it I'm
gonna find her phone number
and I'm gonna call her and I got her on
the phone somehow and I said you know
what for your dad John Houston and my
grandfather John Barrymore who you know
partied here on Earth and are somewhere
up in heaven keeping it going Barrymore
Houston Houston Barrymore we've got to
do this hahaha
the man
it was such a tone for what we're
supposed to be doing here on Earth let's
honor those two men by being these two
women together are you with me
and well she did the film so uh
and Megan is it true you saved something
from the film you have something you
have a relic a thing I do what do you
have
[Music]
foreign